these protesters in the Iraqi Capital
are demanding Justice for the killing of
a young Iraqi YouTuber star tribal Ali
she was strangled by her father in the
southern city of diwania on Tuesday the
attack is being described as a so-called
owner killing Tiba al-ali had reportedly
left her home in Iraq and was living in
Turkey against her family's wishes
we want laws to criminalize domestic
violence the state must guarantee our
safety when we report domestic violence
we've submitted many proposals to the
government but they've all gone unheeded
Tiba returned to her hometown after her
mother reportedly asked her to come back
activists have launched a campaign on
social media with the hashtag tiba's
riot
they're demanding a change to Iraq's
laws which they say give light sentences
to defendants charged with similar
crimes
the parliament is to blame for this
because it's a legislative body that
issues laws to criminalize violence
against women but the parliament itself
is a male-dominated body partly based on
tribal considerations that's part of the
problem
according to activists the victim went
to the interior Ministry for help
but it is not clear if she received any
assistance at all
in a conservative and patriarchal
society like Iraq activists say there
are no effective laws to protect women
from domestic violence
there's also no clear mechanism to
provide shelter for women trying to
escape abuse
so many cases like Ali go unreported
foreign